and I was characterized the NIH CDC in
the FDA or they kind of like the crown
jewels that we have medical be our
efforts this the NIH is absolutely
critical these people that they're
incredibly hard-working they're
incredibly smart but the road to go from
a clean your research to making new
discoveries is a five or 10-year road
and all the people in the lab here
making enormous sacrifices to keep the
United States at the top of biomedical
research and there's got to be some
stability that they've got to understand
that they're going to be able to get the
kinds of research dollars and the grants
that are necessary in order to continue
when they see funding levels drop drop
they pull out of the whole process
because they have to feel like they
something happening for their life in a
very very simply this translates to i
always do with this it's it's the
ability to its really the gift of life
we can save ones and that's what the
what folks were involved in and that's
more than just resources it's what is
essential in terms of the values of this
country there has been great
collaboration yes
there's this you know there's a Yale
excels in getting these effects grains
and there's no because of me it's
because of all of you there's this
translation it's called this gulf
between discovery and academia and drug
development right an industry this
translation the bridge between them two
it's always difficult it requires effort
and if funding pulls back if the economy
makes commercial interests difficult and
if the government pulls back funding
that Gulf becomes wider and we don't
take discoveries into effect and cures
reduce you to think right behind your
sexy lady lovely okay thank you for
coming no thank you and buy it they
really going to make some hits with the
nursing yes ours as well yeah it's
really no we're not talking about
workforce today but I no no but you know
the fact is is that with the shortage of
nurses that we have absolutely and it's
it's not the lack of people who want to
vendors is it's because of faculty
because we don't have trained people and
when you cut back those funds to train
students and so forth to do this then
when our capacity is less crazy and
that's an NIH problem that is an NIH
problem the huge problem for us I'm so
glad to see
yeah tell me where what you're working
on so I'm working on how the brain
develops how it connects and just to
explain it very briefly in the human
brain there 100 billion cells and
basically they have to connect like a
computer they have to connect into
circuits so I study how that happens and
I use a simpler system to answer those
questions so I use a small model
organism but with that with that animal
we made a lot of insights that are of
biomedical relevance so one of the
examples is that we recently identified
a gene that conserved and in humans it
causes the disease and we did that with
with NIH ARRA funds the RF yeah those
those ones actually ending soon yes they
are so so so hopefully we can continue
our work with with more NIH funding in
the future so that's what a bit at the
end of the hour of funds and what
happens from there well we have to we
have to we have to get other fund you
know we've been trying to get other
funding but the situation is so hard
that it's the levels of the beylin
levels are so low that basically we
cannot secure funding that that that
research would just stop and you will
have it will have consequences to the to
the findings that we've had because the
investment that was made before won't
come to fruition for human health right
so we're not only we then spend money to
do something and then if we don't
provide the additional fronts to the NIH
then in fact we have whatever the the
wonders of this research then in fact
have been have been have been myself
have been stole a little boost oh that's
nice a wasted but they've been stall
stall see ya Information Center place
this project right now is ganna would
pointed out these funds are
running out and the projects have real
risk of continued support I'm even this
morning just before meeting you i'm
working on a grant revision to get this
funded so but i think there's a real
risk because it's it's just isn't enough
money to go around I need your advocacy
to make sure that the funds are there
not have a particular interest in what
you're doing the cancers yes no I know I
know
is critical I am you were going to say
something I interrupted you home we were
talking about then I Rebecca's were both
mark and Daniel our new faculty members
and yells put a big investment into
getting them started but they need to
have the nih continue their fantastic
work the new leads that they have you
make the you make the case and it's
clear that the we've got real concerns
about the funding at the NIH and but I'm
always an optimist that we can have more
reasonable people come to the conclusion
that the value of the work that's done
here at Yale is is so important and the
investment in the research is so
important that we can prevail and make
sure that we get the kinds of funding is
necessary and I would just a compliment
Yale and so proud to represent the
institutional because of
the quality at the end the intellectual
and investigative the scientific pursuit
here has been able to garner eighty-five
percent of eighty-five percent of the
portfolio in federal research for Yale
comes through the NIH and that doesn't
come through a from politics it doesn't
come through me it comes through the
genius really and the creative minds of
the of the folks who are here